[Musik]
mein Name ist Shiva Alexander ich
arbeite an der Mittelschule Abtenau und
habe dort das Amt für die geistige
Landesverteidigung übernehmen dürfen bin
da auf dieses Seminar ins Felbertal
gekommen ein
herzlichesdirektion 5% der Bevölkerung
auf diesem Planeten leben in einer
Demokratie so wie wir die haben 45
weitere Prozentzahl Demokratie und der
Rest der Kenntnis
Bevölkerung in ihrem Bewusstsein
schärfen ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig
glaube ich Verteidigung in erster Linie
im Kopf dieses Bewusstsein was für ein
hohes Gut die Demokratie und die
Freiheit in unserem Land ist dieses
Bewusstsein schwindet in der Bevölkerung
wir haben leider erleben müssen in den
letzten Jahren wie volatiles ist dass
man wirklich in Freiheit und Sicherheit
leben darf der Krieg in der Ukraine hat
das gezeigt und wir wissen auch dass
neben der militärischen
Landesverteidigung auch die
wirtschaftliche die zivile
Landesverteidigung und vor allem auch
die geistige Landesverteidigung nicht
hoch genug einzuschätzen ist
[Musik]
Ferienende
unser Ziel ist in den Schulen der
Sekundarstufe 1 und Sekundarstufe 2 eine
Referentin oder einen Referenten für
geistige Landesverteidigung zu
etablieren und das
Fortbildungskonzept dieser Menge dann
aufzupassen so dass wir auch hier eine
gewisse Nachhaltigkeit erreichen ja der
wichtigste Schritt ist einmal getan dass
wir vernetzt sind dass wir die
Referenten auf Schulebene kennen und
jetzt diese schulreferenten mit unseren
informationsoffizieren zusammenbringen
dass sich die kennen und gemeinsam auch
die Projekte erarbeiten wir haben da
sofort mit zugangsgespräche gestartet
vierminütige Kurzpräsentationen
vorbereitet die zugangsgespräche waren
sehr spannend und interessant weil man
unterschiedlichste Zugänge bei den
Kollegen gesehen hat wie sie zu dem
stehen und a den Hintergrund der
Kollegen kennenzulernen also das war
sehr sehr spannend zu dem
haben uns natürlich auch Leute das
Bundesheers dabei unterstützen begleitet
ohne uns allerdings da wirklich sehr
sehr viele Informationen zu geben was du
eigentlich ganz konkret von uns Punkte
geben eben persönlichen backgrounds den
beruflichen bekannt und den Zugang den
jeder einzelne von uns zum
Bundeshaushalt
Geographie Geschichte politische Bilder
und Informatik damit die Herrschaften
von Bildungsministerium spüren können
wie unsere Leute auf ihre Zielgruppen
nämlich die Schülerinnen und Schülern
hin ausgebildet werden machen wir
sogenannte zugangsgespräche mit Ihnen wo
Sie sich selbst vorstellen wo Sie Ihren
Zugang zum Bundeswehr und zum
informationsoffizierswesen darlegen und
das in einem Training Setting nur wird
wenn es vergessen wir haben Sie hier mit
Pädagogen zu tun die stehen ja
tagtäglich vor den Schülerinnen und
Schülern das ist der große Unterschied
zu unseren Soldaten und Soldaten aber
auch zivildiendiensteten die das nicht
gewohnt sind nach dem einleitenden
Vorträgen war für mich besonders wichtig
und besonders interessant der Vortrag
zum kritischen Umgang mit Medien der war
insofern gut getan weil er eine perfekte
Überleitung war dass man das eine oder
andere dann bei den Kamin Gesprächen und
vertiefen können hat
spannend war bei den Kamin Gesprächen
auch die Reaktion der einzelnen
Teilnehmern auf die einzelnen Vorträge
die wir im Laufe des Nachmittags so
genossen haben die differenzierten
Meinungen rückwinkel Perspektiven dieser
allgemeine Austausch also das ist ja ein
zentraler Punkt dieses Seminars und das
ist sehr wichtig und richtig wir
arbeiten
bedarfsorientiert nach Wünschen und
Vorgaben auch des
Unterrichtsministeriums und haben das
inhaltlich so designt dass wir gesagt
haben was sind
interessensfelder für diese
Personengruppe Lehrer was interessiert
die und in diesen drei Tagen vermitteln
wir im Tag 1 vor allem militärisches
Basiswissen unternehmenskunde
Unternehmenskultur Strukturen Aufbau und
Gliederung des österreichischen
Bundesheers Takt zwei verwenden wir für
die Bereiche
stellungswesenstellung für den
österreichischen
Staatsbürger für den Wehrpflichtigen für
den Stellungspflichtigen
gehen aber auch in den Bereich
Zeitgeschichte hinein das rundet dann
das ganze inhaltlich ab ich glaube das
Erfolgsgeheimnis ist dass wir sehr viele
interessante Vortragende haben in
verschiedenen Bereichen durchaus nicht
mehr im militärischen Bereich sondern
wieder morgige Tag anzeigen wird auch in
sicherheitspolitischen Bereich in
Einladung des Chefs des
Verfassungsschutzes in Salzburg
beziehungsweise auch
Energiesicherheit aber auch wie diese
Stellen miteinander
zusammenarbeiten und vor allem hier auch
auf regionale Themen Bezug genommen wird
was da passiert ist unglaublich viel
Informationen Raum für Fragen die
auftauchen die ganz vielfältig sind und
manchmal haben wir doch dass dann andere
Themen auch wichtiger geworden sind aber
gerade das ist ja das Schöne dass da
wirklich alle auf unsere Anliegen und
Fragen eingehen und wir wirklich als
erster Hand erfahren wie das abläuft
also die Inhalte die uns hier vermittelt
werden sind im unter gebraucht täglich
einsetzbar wir haben natürlich das
Unterrichtsprinzip der in der
politischen Bildung wo die geistige
Landesverteidigung natürlich vorkommt
und sicherlich nicht von allen Kollegen
auch als solche wahrgenommen wird bzw
auch nicht umgesetzt wird bei mir muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen dadurch dass sie
diese Einblicke hier bekommen ist schon
seit Jahren in diversen Fortbildungen
fortbildungsfahrten und das mehrmals im
Jahr kann ich natürlich das in Ergänzung
zum Unterricht sehr sehr gut verwenden
was zu kritisieren ist dass in den
derzeitigen Schulbüchern für im Fach
Geschichte zumindest
die mir vorliegen diese Inhalte nicht
vorkommen das Bundesheer wird vielleicht
mit zwei drei Worten erwähnt mehr nicht
also wir gehen da absolut
und Bedürfnis
im Bildungsbereich in der Gesellschaft
gehen wir vorbei wenn man daran denken
dass wir junge Männer an der Oberstufe
unterrichten die später zum Bundesheer
gehen aber auch im Unterricht junge
Frauen haben oder auch Schülerinnen und
Schüler mit nicht
österreichische Staatsbürgerschaft die
aber hier leben und hier wahrscheinlich
auch bleiben werden die erreichen wir
nicht wenn ich Inhalte zudem hier
angesprochenen Themen erst im Rahmen des
Grundwertes behandeln
es ist sehr sehr spannend und
interessant von den Input her
persönlich kann ich nur sagen es waren
einige Elemente dabei die für meine
weitere Tätigkeit des Lehrer mitnehmen
kann wenn gewünscht wird zweitens das
Unterrichtsministeriums oder seitens der
Bildungsdirektionen in denen
Bundesländern steht das österreichische
Bundesheer auch hier quasi als Assistenz
und Dienstleister zur Verfügung
diese Inhalte auch einer anderen
Personengruppe in diesem konkreten Fall
halt zu informieren und weiterzugeben
wenn es österreichweit geplant und
gewünscht wird stehen wir unseren Mann
unsere Frau
geplant im ideal wäre ein
kontinuierlicher Austausch
auf Landesebene bzw Bundesebene auf dem
Bereich des
informationsoffizierswesen der sich
jetzt mit den Lehrern in einer neuen
Form präsentiert der informationsoffen
sehr extern wir jetzt genannt wird ein
Lehrer der sozusagen die inhaltliche und
fachliche Qualifikation erhalten hat
wer politische Inhalte und Experten in
einer Schule zu geben
hier würde sich ein bundesweites Format
anbieten als auch wird angestrebt und
wir hoffen darauf dass es auf
Landesebene kontinuierlich weiter
betrieben wird
[Musik]